hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
where we track the changes happening to
our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions
we're a week into the olympics and
there's a warning that these games could
be the hottest
ever held extreme heat is nothing new in
tokyo
but experts say the role of
human-induced climate change
is making it worse now according to the
japanese meteorological agency
japan and more specifically tokyo is
warming much
faster than the rest of the planet the
mean temperature in the country's
capital
has increased by 2.86 degrees
since 1900 that's nearly three times
faster than the world's average
and part of the reason tokyo experiences
such high temperatures
is because of the urban heat island
effect this is where an
urban area is significantly warmer than
its surrounding rural areas
due to heat being created by all the
people transport and buildings
it means that during the night the
surface of the largely urbanized tokyo
area
releases heat that's been trapped during
the day preventing the city from cooling
now heat waves are a natural part of the
climate system
however human-induced global warming is
making them stronger
and more frequent scientists predict
that extremely hot temperatures in japan
will become the new normal if the
world's temperature increases by one and
a half degrees celsius
above pre-industrial levels now in a
sporting context
a hot and humid environment can
represent a risk to the performance and
health of spectators
officials and of course athletes as
sky's tom parmenter reports from tokyo
it is sweltering and every outdoor sport
is feeling it
we've had athletes collapsing and some
events moved away from the middle of the
day
we got here it was a bit of a shock i'm
not gonna lie but yeah so you're getting
used to it
at home we were in greenhouses hot pods
just kind of sweat on with um layers as
well math face masks training face masks
so as soon as we got here and it
definitely felt like that
as much as the heat the humidity is
sapping their strength
it is punishing out there and each of
them have to carefully manage it so
there's more drinks more breaks
they could easily overcook themselves
this was johnny brownlee's preparation
chamber
in his conservatory in yorkshire yes
that is sweat
but when it's for real there is no
escape it's not an unusually hot summer
in tokyo but researchers here have
calculated that the average temperature
has increased faster here than in other
parts of the world
up three degrees over the past century
now with the athletics underway the
middle and long distance runners
have to find their climate control it's
just
so much harder uh straight in the body
on the heart rate everything is just
more increased and it's actually just
the perception of
not being able to cool down as well
which is quite difficult to
so not only is it physically i think
mentally sometimes you need to be
i suppose reassured that you're not just
going to implode
the hot rain that sometimes drops in
doesn't clear the humidity
we're on the 28th floor and you can't
see any of tokyo now and then it clears
again
the midsummer games here are tough but
the heat
is just one of the many challenges tom
parmenter
sky news tokyo well joining me now is
melissa wilson
british rower and member of champions
for earth melissa thank you very much
indeed
for joining us now it's just three years
ago that a heatwave in japan claimed the
lives of more than a thousand people
thousands were hospitalized again last
summer how much of a concern was the
weather and the heat for
athletes competing at tokyo
yeah a huge concern both for the
athletes and for
their coaching teams and physiology
teams behind them as we heard from
some of the long-distance runners just
then people have been in heat chambers i
know the
sailing squads the hockey teams have
been looking at that and alice deering
in the open water she's preparing for
swimming in water that over 10
kilometers that is going to be
at least 29 degrees so she's been in
these tanks of hot water trying to train
and acclimatize
just to face the competition that she's
going to have this summer
and how much does climate change concern
you when it comes to competing
your sport an outdoor event rowing uh
it's not just heat that impacts you but
also potentially extreme weather which
we're seeing
a lot more of yeah
absolutely we had two days of racing
postponed because of the typhoon that
came in
and i was talking to one of the tokyo
rose this morning he came away with the
silver medal and he was saying in terms
of heat
just for their half hour training
sessions which is really quite a light
load
easy steady state they were losing up to
2
liters of water just in that half hour
period in their training in the week
leading up to the game
so it's definitely something that will
weigh on the minds of these athletes and
especially when they're trying to make
strategic decisions as well in the
course of a rowing race
it's hard to keep that clarity of
thought when your body physiologically
is under such extreme pressures
well melissa we have really appreciated
having your thoughts today thanks very
much indeed for joining us
in today's other climate news enough ice
melted in greenland
to cover florida with two inches of
water in just
a day the world meteorological
organizations say the country lost more
than
eight and a half billion tons of surface
mass from an ice melt
on tuesday scientists predict
greenland's ice melt will raise sea
levels between
2 and 10 centimeters by the end of the
century putting coastal cities
at risk of flooding
environmentalists say pollution has
caused this lagoon in argentina to turn
pink look at that the pink hue is
thought to be caused by waste sodium
sulfite
used by fish farms to clean shrimp now
while the striking shade of pink may
look pretty
water treatment specialists say the
contamination is killing the chance of
any kind of life
surviving in the water and the natural
history museum has opened a new
exhibition on the consequences of
climate change
and the potential solutions director
doug gur told sky news the museum
will walk the walk on its promise to
reach net zero by 2035.
and to find out more you can listen to
the interview with mr gur on this week's
episode of climatecast and you can find
that wherever you normally get your
podcasts
countries in africa are being asked to
make big climate commitments ahead of
the cop 26 summit in november
now these include reducing emissions and
investment in renewable energy
in order to keep the level of global
warming to one and a half degrees above
pre-industrial levels now according to
the united nations africa is the
continent
most vulnerable to the impacts of
climate change
countries there face a wide range of
impacts including increased drought and
floods
as well as decreasing food production
and loss of biodiversity
but despite being so vulnerable to the
effects of climate change
africa is not a significant source of
greenhouse gas emissions
you can see here emissions from regions
worldwide from 1965
all the way through to 2020 and asia
pacific
is by far the biggest contributor in
recent years
with china alone responsible for nearly
60 percent of those
followed by north america and then
europe in comparison
africa has consistently contributed a
very small percentage of co2 emissions
the presidents of kenya and malawi have
spoken to sky news
and explained what they think the
pressing issues are ahead of cop 26.
we were all in paris a few years ago
the enormous pledges for
adaptation and mitigation that were made
and here we are now heading to glasgow
with very few of those commitments
actually lived upon
we need to be able to get to a situation
where we walk the talk
and do what we say and my hope and my
prayer is that
moving into glasgow we are going to get
more realism and that is why i'm saying
we need all parties at the table
this issue of climate change has
affected us
and our irregular rain patterns have
affected us badly but through it all
we are having to take measures where
food sufficiency becomes
foremost let's bring in our africa
correspondent john sparks
john thanks very much indeed for joining
us now of course one of the big things
is food security can you put into
context for us how climate change is
impacting people's lives in africa
already
that's right it's interesting isn't it
sally food security probably not the
first thing
you think of in the developed world when
you talk about climate change but it
sure is
here in africa the fact is tens of
millions of people
on the continent live life on the edge
they live a hand-to-mouth
existence and when weather patterns
change people go hungry
and we saw that in south sudan recently
rains have washed out hundreds of
kilometers of
of prime farmland and that water had
been accumulating since 2018.
nobody had any seen anything like it and
in madagascar currently the world food
program
is saying that entire communities are
teetering on the edge
of starvation after a severe two-year
drought really serious problem and as a
consequence the world's
poorest countries they want loans and
grants
to help fight and adapt to climate
change and they're becoming increasingly
vocal about it as well but the developed
world still haven't met
their commitments in terms of 100
billion
dollars of climate finance and that was
a target that was set back in 2009
so there sure is a lot to do that
certainly is john thanks very much
indeed for joining us
staying in africa now because tomorrow
is world rangers day
a day to recognize the work being done
to conserve the environment
now team lioness is one of kenya's first
all-female wildlife
ranger units the group used their
relationships with massify women in the
area
to protect their national park from harm
what is your name my name is piriti
lakara
trim learning
it was my vision to come and protect
regulation future
we wake up at 5 00 a.m
we go for morning run after we take
baths we take cheese then
we arrange ourselves for the patrol
here we see the footprint of algebra
[Music]
cleanliness and can lead to drought and
this drought can cause
some wildlife like lions and elephants
to change their position they can move
from
the national park to around the
communities
in search of water and pastures animals
like lion can enter into
bombers they kill their livestocks and
this leads to human wildlife conflict
[Music]
then if they go to interact with ladies
in the
in our community they can't get
information
easily this is a
horn of an envelope maybe it has
brought when they are fighting with each
other
for us as ladies we can graduate the
community and get
information easily because we live with
them like our mothers our sisters
so it is very easy for us to interact
with them and to get information
i hope that in the future many women
will be
empowered and i'm hopeful for the future
of the land that
i am protecting i am hoping that maybe
deforestation will not be there
because we protect all species of
wildlife and plants also
and finally a little happy news trail
cameras have captured footage
of the first baby beaver born in norfolk
for 600 years
now the beaver known as a kit was
spotted swimming at
wild ken hill a stretch of land being
restored to its natural state
beavers once native to norfolk have been
reintroduced to the area
because their dams create ponds and
streams in turn
restoring local wetlands well that's
everything from us for this week don't
forget you can keep up with all the
climate news over the weekend on our
website
just head to sky news dot com forward
slash climate
thanks very much indeed for joining us
i'll see you next week
[Music]